là aussi la démarche de voltaire et la
démarche de na li yang est la même dans
la chanson dina liang vous qu on fait le
constat empirique du mal qui existe
voilà un mariage qu'elle on n'aurait pas
pensé voltaire et neil young partagent
le même idée donc candide et rocking in
the free world
[Musique]
à la guitare francis métivier professeur
de philosophie amateurs de rock'n'roll
et créateur du rock'n philo ça remonte à
l'adolescence en fait j'ai découvert à
la fois le rock et la philosophie en
prenant conscience sur fond que les deux
avaient des messages à des
questionnements et des messages à peu
près équivalent évidemment exprimé dans
des formes très très différentes mais il
ya un point commun qui est le côté un
peu contestataire la remise en cause de
l'ordre établi que ce soit chez socrate
en philosophie par exemple ou chez dylan
dans le domaine de la folk song après un
premier ouvrage du même nom en 2011
francis métivier prend sa guitare et
monte sur scène accompagné de christian
jeantet et philippe du janerand
[Musique]
ma gueule qui va me permet d'expliquer
la liberté chez sartre le regard de
l'autre qui me prive de ma liberté c'est
un questionnement qui intéresserait les
gens parce que c'est vraiment un thème
philosophique et rock 1 les deux faces
est pas le seul un ignorer le désirent y
aurait l'amour y aurait plein l'histoire
aurait plein de choses les spectateurs
n'ont pas eu de copie à rendre à l'issue
de secours concert et ont goûté à la
liberté
be nice
[Musique]